so what would you advise to other
documentarians I know this is not your
first documentary amongst the two of you
you've done others how would you
approach someone however have what
advice would you give to another
would-be filmmaker or established
filmmaker on approaching someone because
I'm sure there's a gentle process to it
you don't want to seem too eager but at
the same time when I move on quickly
because they're probably busy I I think
what i think is a documentary filmmaker
the film finds you a little bit right if
you keep your eyes and ears open and and
wait to feel that like sort of thing
that makes you move forward right that's
a big part of it and and it was very
lucky and I and I feel like we were the
right we we feel like we were the right
people to do this story we were both in
a in a place where we had recently given
birth we both cared about the topic a
lot and already sort of knew a lot about
the topic just because it are our lives
have led us in that direction but i also
think when in approaching IMA we we
approached it very well you know we held
it very lightly in other words we said
like well let's see let's just take the
first step toward getting to know her
let's agree that will come and we'll do
an interview for a long weekend and and
it doesn't mean we're going to make a
movie it doesn't mean you're going to
sign a release form it just means we're
gonna come and we're going to get to
know you we're going to get a feel for
what's there and and so that went really
well and I think our questions helped
her to feel comfortable she's sort of
got a sense of what kinds of things we
were thinking about and and so then we
were able to start to structure the
conversation a little bit more well we'd
like to make a feature film about you
this is you know I remember we sat in
her bedroom and she sort of said like
well what would this be like but you
always start out with some naivete when
you're starting a film I mean it's just
you know you have the enthusiasm that
you don't realize this film we didn't
realize going into it the film would
take four years to make and you know but
I also just want to add to that that I
think that
it's chemistry you know in einem a said
to us I've had people come to me and
want to make a film before but I never
had two mothers come to me and she said
I've always trusted my intuition that's
how it made decisions throughout my
whole life and this is no different and
it was just it was a conversation on her
bed like she said she said okay let's
let's just go forward and you know we
were so thrilled we were nervous and we
wanted to show her that we were the
right people but it it was it was about
chemistry I think to and and like Sarah
said we weren't you know we were
chomping at the bit but we also thought
well if it doesn't work out at least we
we were able to spend time with this
great woman and have one interview yeah
our first trip we said let's just do one
interview we were there for three days
really that's all we really need to do
and that interview is actually sort of
the spine of the whole film so yeah so
sounds like sort of a non-committal type
II or too pushy about it just let's just
see if this works yeah and then the
chemistry was right and she sounds
actually felt safe with I think she was
in at a point in her life to her she was
ready for this to happen you know she
was that I think the second trip that we
made to Tennessee she turned 70 and she
was kind of looking back on all the work
that she's done and her popularity is
you know rising and I think that you
know the the sort of system is a little
bit broken in people are hungry for
different information and I think she
was ready for it and she's been filmed
throughout her her whole life I mean at
least since the beginning of the farm
they were always there were you know
always news programs of you know where
they were featured they had a navy crew
throughout the seven
these that had the foresight to film
everything so she's very comfortable on
camera and so that's another thing it
wasn't like talking someone into it who
had never been in a situation you know
in front of a camera and felt
uncomfortable she she's quite
comfortable in front of a camera seems
like a lot of documentary subjects have
been consciously or subconsciously
waiting for the camera crew to turn up
there in spider
you